you're gonna have to get used to asking
questions that might make you a little
bit uncomfortable
philosophy is predicated on the idea
that
truth is a good that we desire
every particular question you have about
justice
or happiness or the good has behind
it a whole series of assumptions you're
making about the nature of reality
many people think about philosophy as a
process
of destroying all of your basic beliefs
about reality
but in truth philosophy is about
bringing us
more deeply into the truth about reality
what is the good what is the will what
is the unifying cause
what's at the beginning of everything
you know the first line in aristotle
metaphysics is a human being is made to
know
desires to know it's hard to know but we
love to know don't we
and these courses are about things that
let us understand
eternal things and judge temporal things
in light of them what we will see
is that philosophy is a human journey
something in us wants to know the truth
about reality
it is the human condition to live by
ideas
and not just by instincts or
inclinations or passions
our ideas about human nature about god
about economics and about politics all
have consequences and so the question is
not
why do we study philosophy
[Music]
man is condemned to philosophize
the only question is will he
philosophize well
or poorly let's begin